the david pakman show subreddit now has
nearly 15,000 of our audience members
subscribed and participating in
political discussion news discussion
suggesting stories for the show you can
find the subreddit at david pakman.com
slash our EDD i.t a couple of notable
threads i noticed this morning one is
from a user named future Microsoft guy
who says sudden anti-war in videos from
progressive YouTube outlets asking what
has caused all the sudden anti Warren
videos think it has to do with where she
is in the polls kyle kolinsky and jimmy
dore a made some points but seems it was
brought on more so due to poll numbers
being better than Bernie what does
everyone make of this listen here here's
the reality I've tried to tell this like
it is from the beginning Elizabeth
Warren is not as progressive as Bernie
Sanders her political origins are far
more conservative than the origins of
Bernie Sanders where she ends up today
on policy is to the right of Bernie
Sanders but I'm not going to smear
Elizabeth Warren I've reported she said
in the general she would accept money
from sources that Bernie Sanders would
not I forget the exact list if it's PACs
corporations whatever it is but her
position is she's not going to
participate in unilateral disarmament if
the other side if she is the nominee
she's not going to jeopardize her
chances of winning as she sees it you
can disagree with that I think there are
serious moral questions to that position
there are the differences between Bernie
and Warren on Medicare for all Bernie is
all for it with a specific plan
Elizabeth Warren is into the idea but
claims there is not a specific plan and
is open to other options I've been
totally transparent about it but either
either of them would be the most
progressive presidents that the United
States has never had in the modern
political era and I don't know what
other shows are doing I don't watch
other shows but I'm not going to
participate in smearing Elizabeth Warren
when she would be the most progressive
president we've ever had Bernie would be
more progressive sure but I'm not gonna
participate in what this person says is
happening on other other channels which
I have not seen I just don't watch other
shows
like this one I watch other stuff
another post from the subreddit tulsi
tulsi gabbard comes out against
impeachment proceedings and a lot of
people are furious about this listen i
am going to address the Tulsi things
sort of I don't really care what Tulsi
does like I mean I I know that there's a
big cult of personality around Tulsi
Gabbard she is one of 435 members of
Congress there are like 18 Democrats I
think who are not in favor of the
impeachment inquiry against Donald Trump
I quite frankly find myself relatively
unmoved like okay she's not for it I
just don't care in the same way that I
wouldn't care if Bill DeBlasio was
against it or who Leon Castro or anybody
else who has no shot at the Democratic
nomination I just had a really hard time
even getting upset or concerned about
what Tulsi gabbard's position is she's
not for it you know good for her join
the discussion at david pakman.com slash
our IDI di tea